le chercheur guillet bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue c'est dans des moments comme
celui ci où où vous tape sur l'épaule
pour venir discuter de moments
difficiles on parle par exemple bien sûr
de de l'événement qui s'est passé à
québec la tuerie où vous avez parlé
votre texte votre vos paroles ont ont
fait presque le tour de la planète même
jk rowling qui vous a écrit vous vous
parler maintenant aussi dans la foulée
de ceux de cet événement qui est un
référendum cet appui nerfs qui a refusé
l'installation d'un cimetière musulman
puis là maintenant des gestes odieux de
méchanceté à communauté musulmane avec
ses messages haineux est ce que c'est
une boucle qui revient et qui revient et
qui revient encore et toujours
je vais répondre a voté l'interdiction
avant je trouve que j'ai à la tma qu'à
l'ère des pompiers en position
d'éteindre lé feu et seconde c'est pour
ça on m'appelle dans des moments
critiques comme ça parce que j'ai cette
façon et pouvoir calmer les gens de
pouvoir amener les gens à rassurer le
monde et panser les blessures le fait
travailler les gens ensemble est ce qu
on revient à la case départ on ne pense
pas la seule chose après les événements
tragiques du mois de janvier il ya et il
y avait toute une vague de solidarité et
de sympathie et on était très fier des
saints on était content même s'il a dit
sur la colline parlementaire quand je
suis vivant j'étais invité pour parler
pour les son 50e anniversaire
j'ai dis qu'est qu'on lit tous les
câbles quand les canada tout entier
s'est dressée et à crier haut et fort
non à la violence non au racisme qu'ont
les canadiens se sont transformés en
chaîne humaine à travers les p -o
protéger les masses qui est quand même
le coeur de tous les canadiens se sont
transformées en mosquées
nous avons réalisé que nous sommes une
seule famille
malgré toutes nos différences et qu'il
est banon ne vont pas issue à nous
diviser
cette société la nôtre et on va la
défendre ont bâti cette société ensemble
quand vous êtes cette société la nôtre
c'est dans un singe de participation et
non pas de propriétés communiste puis
tout le monde mais on appartient à cette
heure nous sommes des citoyens contre le
monde nous avons les mêmes droits que
tout le monde et nous avons les mêmes
des voix quand on n'est pas plus pas
moins
donc nous sommes des citoyens nous
sommes pas des étrangers nous sommes pas
des passages ici et c'est pour ça on
essaye d'avoir une proximité a ici parce
que comme nous vivons sur la face de
cette terre on aimé pouvoir se faire
enterrer dans sa terre aussi il y à
quelques voix qui nous accusent des pas
pour vouloir s'intégrer
je me demande quel niveau d'intégration
plus et que de vouloir se faire enterrer
vendre la terre ou en vie donc
l'argument du poids vous est donc
effectivement cette société est la nôtre
pays et le nôtre et tous les canadiens
et tous les québécois de toutes les
religions sont nos confrères sont nos
partenaires dont
dans la vie et ils devront il faut qu'on
travaille ensemble dans des incidents
par des parcours comme celui de
saint-apollinaire comme celui du collier
et on allait chez vendredi doit pas nous
arrêter d'essayer dé continuer à
travailler ensemble
vous êtes vous appelez ça des incidents
de parcours oui j'appelle ça des
incidents départ comme est je vais pas
banaliser au contraire et appelle à tous
les québécois et tous les canadiennes
des bonnes volontés des cdc comme ils
sont décédés 29 janvier ce qui arrive on
se rend compte que la majorité des
québécois et des canadiens sont contre
la violence et sur contre la haine
contre la discrimination et contre
l'islamophobie
malheureusement il y à une certaine
minorité très minime mais elle est très
très active si on va sur les médias
sociaux
on pense que tous les québec et
l'assisté islamophobe qui est pas vrai
la malle malheureusement la majorité des
québécoises la majorité des québécois en
sont une majorité silencieuse et si ça
il faut qu'on continue à être une
majorité et mais il faut qu'on avait
deux touchés l'ont su il faut qu'on soit
des plus en plus éloquent est présent
pour dire non à la violence non à la
discrimination non à l'islamophobie
d'ailleurs j'ai dit ça à messieurs les
bons mais lui même personnellement pour
maire de québec nomades et qui va
évidemment on était dans une activité
j'ai été appelé à parler avant moi et
après il fallait qu'ils jugent pas
d'après lui c'est donc l'heure des
obsèques c'était l'inversé moi
j'appellerai avant lui puis j'ai demandé
j'ai trouvé qu'il était anormal n'est
pas avoir incité à pour les musulmans
même qu'on les vendéens 3ème 4ème
génération élevée ni après mois et nous
appelons mais les cimetières
quelques mois après il avait un
événement pour lui merci tout sucre qui
ont travaillé pour aider les victimes de
c'est dans ce qui suit la bombe était là
et moi aussi mais cette fois ci c'est
lui qui a parlé avant moi quand louis
il a dit dans son discours que il y at
il quelque chose
que je préfère qu'on qu'il nous faut que
nous pouvons faire qu'on n'a pas fait
encore dit puis après quand j'ai parlé
du oui missionnement vous allez poser la
question vous méritez une réponse oui là
quelque chose vous pouvez faire vous et
tous ceux qui sont ici menace al c'est
que si on va sur les médias sociaux on
va entendre la voix de la haine et la
paella manipulation et l'amalgamme et
l'ignorance parce que tous les gens qui
sont assis dans la salle ils prennent
pas la peine d répondre aux de
téléphonie mobile téléphonie qui prend
même pas la peine de répondre aux
messages sur les réseaux sociaux et les
gens on envoie un très mauvais message
en pense que la majorité des québécois
sont sont partisans de la haine de la
haine et des l'islamophobie
donc je vous demande à vous
personnellement à tous ceux qui sont
dans la salle à toutes les québécois et
québécoises honnête d'être des plans de
la parole et démontrer les vraies
valeurs du québec lévis les valeurs du
canada l'agriculture québécoise est
culture canadienne qui sont des cultures
d'ouverture et d'égalité des fratries à
sanglier qu'est ce que vous répondez aux
gens qui parlent d'un d'ouvrir des
cimetières mais multiconfessionnel si je
prends par exemple le cas des cimetières
militaires
beaucoup en europe se côtoient des
pierres tombales de chrétiens de juifs
instruite
ici je vais je vais pas commenter les
cimetières militaires parce que les
soldats en temps surtout en europe les
vous mais palais de l'europe
les soldats et qui sont tombés ces tv
sont d'accord dans la mer française ou
l'allemagne où canadien ne beaucoup
d'armes de poing ce sens oui mais s'ils
ont lâché les commandes militaires quand
la liberté d'expression la liberté de
religion les bleus s'étaient pas la
norme donc plutôt d'essayer de faconde
et d'essayer démilitarisé notre société
civile
il faut aussi briser mais non oui
d'accord mais si on revient à ce constat
au début j'avais une question c'est que
les cimetières multiconfessionnelle ne
sont pas content ici multiconfessionnel
on vit dans un pays démocratique et
libre chaque citoyen a le droit
d'exercer ses droits et des pratiques et
sa conviction il y à des cimetières
musique confessionnelles ceux et celles
qui veulent faire enterrés dans un
cimetière mais il faut fonctionnel qui
aille qu'il les fasse ci est quelqu'un
qui vit ici matière laïque
ainsi thierry qui a qu'il ait fait ce
qu'on object pas à ça mais comme les
catholiques peuvent avoir leur chimie
tiers comme les juifs peuvent avoir la
chimie tiers comme les allées tout mon
intervention sur son cimetière
pourquoi la question s'est posée
seulement aujourd'hui parce qu'on essaye
d'avoir un cimetière musulman
pourquoi la question et
multiconfessionnel ses impôts seulement
aux musulmans pourquoi pas aux autres -
puisque tout le monde le sait je suis
dit je viens des petites localités qui
s'appelle série mis sur la rive sud de
montréal qui est monochrome très très
canadienne française
effectivement et il y à un tambour d'une
personne était connu qui est les ped et
notre prime
myst justin trideau donc pierre elliott
trudeau et ses ancêtres sont enterrés à
saint rémi dans un cimetière catholique
exclusivement catholique
ça m'a jamais dérangé ça n'a jamais
dérangé personne
des fois je m'en vais dans cette danse
est imité à blâmer les cueillir au
tombeau des bielles et le trio parce que
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour lui quand
je suis venu au canada c'est lui qui
étaient les premiers jeux du canada
donc ça m'a jamais jamais touvé qui
s'établiront aussi si je suis content
d'avoir un cimetière catholique
quand je vais aller faire maquiller elle
fait pour me faire ma prière dans une
mosquée quand un catholique fait sa
prière et les faits dans une église
comme elle j'ai vu faire sa prière et
les faits dans une synagogue
ça veut pas dire qu'on veut pas
s'intégrer l'un à l'autre savait pas
dire qu'on aime pas l'un l'autre savait
pas dire qu'on veut pas vivre l'un avec
l'autre mais il ya des spécificités des
convictions et des religions qu'il faut
qu'on respecte ça et d'ailleurs la
charte canadienne des droits respectés
et surtout les droits de la propriété
privée comme je le droit d'acheter une
maison
gl de racheter intérêts des terrains
pour faire un suivi t il à la question
qui se pose c'est quoi sur les zonages
il faut qu'ils sachent que ça respecte
les lois environnementales les
règlements de l'environnement je suis
d'accord avec ça et ceci me tiennent la
ces projets là ces territoires la
respecte et tout ça est sis à l'ironie
de la démocratie il ya seulement deux
personnes qui ont réussi à tuer les
projets ou au moins bloqué les projets
pour le moment les tuer ou non on va
voir pourquoi on dit des parce qu'elles
étaient des gens peuvent me corriger 10
91 19 n'ose y ait deux parce que 19
contre et 16 pour sylis et en dépêchant
sur les dix neuf comme on comptait 6 à
l'ironie de la démocratie
là aussi une autre chose c'est que
pourquoi seulement si peu parce que pour
faire ainsi me tiens et parce que selon
lui les gens dans l'ancien
loi qui était maintenant changé il
fallait s' il ya un référendum mais il
faut qu'ils sont les gens qui habitent
dans les secteurs limitrophes au sound
of donc quand on fait ainsi mutés on les
fait pas au centre-ville ont une classe
où c'était lancement populaire public
donc on le fait dans des places isolé
donc c'était ce terrain là et contre les
chemins de fer le tour de fin à une
place très loin cette voie ça dérangeait
personne et derrière ça diront les
personnes parce qu'il était sonné pour
l'intimité mais maintenant aussitôt
qu'on a dit ainsi mutés à musulmans là
c'était l'enfer
c'est une chose une focale appelle un
chat un chat
s'il est fait d'être musulman qui
dérangeait pas l'effet d'avoir un
cimetière
ça s'était joué une autre chose les gens
qui disent ah oui mais lily les
musulmans un fonds pain puis les gens
sont mêlés les québécois s'ils sont
menacés c'est pas vrai la preuve c'est
que 62 personnes qui avaient le droit
d'aller voter
il ya seulement 49 qui sont allés
enregistrer leur nom sur les 49 il est
seulement 36 qui ont voté un vote ont
été annulées 19 contre et 16 pour si les
gens s'ils sont menacés à ce point là il
aurait pu se déplacer pour voter
si moi je vois qu'il ya lui fait ou les
dangers du fait de ma maison j'écoute je
suis pour l'éteindre
une fois je suis allé chez dumas maison
j'allais je sais pas où
puis la gc mais la plaie cij a fermé les
fûts ou non parce que j'avais quelque
chose sur le feu j'ai appelé ma femme
jeudi quitte ton emploi tout de suite
c'est à dire tout de suite va à la
maison vérifier parce que j'ai un petit
doute que j'ai pas fermer les feux puis
à la légalité les pma terrain avec toi
l'oeuf était fermé donc on sait sont les
moins de danger on agit si les québécois
où les résidents descente apollinaire
son télé moi dedans j'y serais venu
voter en masse juste les manque
d'intérêt les manque d'implication sa
peau jusqu'à quel point les gens sont si
sont à menace
nous sommes donc qu est ce qu on avait
cette campagne car il y avait certaines
personnes qui étaient manipulés
certaines personnes qui étaient
manipulés comme un manipulateur
ils ont réussi à manipuler un certain
nombre étaient minimes
mais la majorité des québécois de la
majorité des canadiens n'ont pas à ma
connaissance de l'islam n'ont pas peur
des musulmans
il y a dix l'amour savait pas dire qu'il
a pas de l'islamophobie il ya
d'islamophobie
il faut qu'on travaille contre
l'islamophobie et g passe passe mon
temps à conditionner par des politiciens
de nos chers politiques et les dangers
et la faisons quelque chose contre
l'islamophobie comme il ya des lois pour
climatique criminaliser l'antisémitisme
ça prend des loi pour criminaliser
l'islamophobie l'islamophobie
l'islamophobie aussi parce que c'est un
vrai danger c'est un concert et c'est
pas juste les musulmans qui sont menacer
pas l'islamophobie
c'est la société tout entière un
incident de parcours mais un parcours
qui est en cours à sanguinet merci
beaucoup merci